Tucker Carlson New York Times released
his address did they or I see I only I
claimed that they were gonna I literally
only saw it from yours they do [__] like
that they did it with like I just can't
you know listen man I don't watch Tucker
I don't care so yeah he says something
I'm like that makes sense sometimes he
says something I'm like that's wrong I
love all these people that are so
committed to like hating a guy or loving
I'm like oh what I just watched a guy
every now and then I go yeah I don't
think so how did we get there though how
do we get where people because I noticed
sometimes I I'll notice I'll fall into
it if I really let myself yeah but then
I notice I'm not an activist right like
people crave uh there's a few things
about people they crave drama they crave
fights it's back to the days of the
Roman Coliseum oh yeah I'd like to see
combat now there is no real Combat right
now so a lot of people are sitting on a
couch and they're on the computer so the
combat is all internet It's All Digital
they love that
um I also think that people are just
they want to be slaves people want to
generally be in a group and to have
allies and then have another group that
they hate yeah it's just what it is and
it's like
I don't know what that is somebody might
be able to explain that behavioral
psychologist or somebody I don't know
people just like having friends that
they connect with and they get these
friends by having the same enemies and
the same allies so you can't look at a
guy like Tucker Carlson ago he's a human
being and then he might be wrong about
things
um you you look at him as an enemy of
you he's a direct enemy of you
um uh because he espouses a different
political ideology because you think
that he's making life unsafe for people
because of what he believes yeah and
some of them might have some some some
some relevance you know like I get it if
you're undocumented immigrant you know
obviously your opinion of uh Trump is
probably very different than a guy like
me who has the luxury of being like hey
I'm not getting deported right right
um that doesn't mean
every political argument you're ever
going to have There's real life
consequences and real people are going
to be affected that doesn't mean you
can't have a political argument about
immigration right doesn't mean you can't
talk about abortion yeah some people
think that the bats are in one lane that
they have to stay in that lane for
everything yeah or they think that if
they can you know yeah
school shootings are horrible I don't
want them to happen I'm for all kinds of
gun regulations but just because people
real people are affected by some I mean
the reason we're talking about it is
because people are affected right the
reason it's an issue in general is
because people are affected and if you
shut down dialogue then what are people
supposed to do so these emotional
appeals that a lot of people have on the
left and the right where they're just
like but what about that kids what about
that b it's like yeah but how did we get
here how do we get to the kids in the
cages it's not having an immigration
policy it's not having any agreed upon
policy that's how we got here so we need
to figure out a way to have a policy
that makes sense yeah yeah and there has
to be it's also like we always want
everyone else to do everything it's like
the government all of it is just Society
it's just the best we can do right now
right it's like some people act like
every everything should be different
everything should be different if it was
supposed to be different right now yeah
it would be different this is the best
we can do to have one of the best
Societies in the world I wonder if
sometimes my Boomer parents might make
fun of all the time but like sometimes
my dad was right when he was just like
like every time somebody bring up
politics my father would just be like I
can't get involved yeah it's really it's
the best thing he goes I just can't get
involved like like he just like like
there's a certain level of like if
you're gonna get in it get in it run for
something yeah really get in there but
we can have a society where every
[__] human being is a cable news
anchor yeah we can't I can't be in line
at Starbucks and and people are you know
in a heated political debate at eight
o'clock in the morning we can't do it
well it's unhealth there's more to life
that's the other thing about politics
dude it's more to life go camping go
read a book go love someone yeah and it
really it gets so it's such an addictive
thing and it's funny like the biggest
Addiction in the world right now really
is uh people consuming things that they
like like the news really media that
they know is bad for them but they wake
up and they go to it again and again
let's just do it yeah let's just do it
anyway and they know it's and it's a bro
that is an addiction because they do it
to feed something inside of themselves
they do it because it's easier for you
to sit there and be angry any of us and
I don't mean someone but all of us it's
easier for us to sit there and be angry
than it is to take action and make our
lives better a hundred percent a hundred
percent I think this is an escape and I
think people escape into this world
instead of fixing the world that is very
close to them yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one